Dark Souls
Remastered releases on the 25th of May which should tie  us over until we hear more about
Shadows die twice later in the year on screen
I'm going to put all the new specs for your systems, and these frame rates they passed the test
It's going to feature a six player online in PvE or PvP
Which is up from four players
And it's also going to include the new password systems that have been included in recent games
Which is a really great addition
We'll also be getting dedicated servers for what I believe is the first time which has interesting implications
going forward
I always wish that they would invest a bit more in their PvP systems
And this is a sign that they're doing that and finally a number of bug fixes and improvements
have been submitted by some members of the community in the past year or so.
So you can expect the more egregious problems in the game to have been addressed probably?
Apart from all of that though. We know very little about how much of a pure
remaster this is and
Namco has been really quick to clarify that the game will not include any new assets based on the Dark Souls 3
Engine or any combat differences, but no combat differences really
Dark Souls ones engine has aged quite a bit and I'd be very
Surprised if they didn't tweak a few small things like
backstabs or omnidirectional
Movement while you're locked on and I think I speak for most people here when I say I'd also love to see
tweaks to some of the rushed areas of the game. The obvious example that everyone is throwing out is Lost Izalith and
You know I can't imagine being from software and not wanting to fix these examples of rushed development after all these years
Yes, there's a certain magic to keeping them exactly the same Bed of Chaos is kind of special because of how terrible
that boss fight is but there's a really strong argument to be made for tweaking a few things as well and
With the introduction of dedicated servers for what I believe is the first time
I can't imagine that they'd be leaving covenants untouched as well especially with how bare-bones they were in Dark Souls 1
So I wouldn't lose hope regarding some nice upgrades to the gameplay
just yet, but bear in mind that there are no promises on this front all evidence at this point indicates that this will be a
Remaster that is very similar to the experience of Dark Souls 1, but regardless of how much they change and while I do
Hope they change a lot and keep it fresh
It's gonna be a hell of an experience for new and old players alike
Because to so many of us Dark Souls is what started it all
It's the gold standard for level design in souls because it has that amazing
Interwoven map structure that I really wish they replicated more in future games
this is the game where I fell in love with PvP the hardest and
now there's going to be this new huge resurgence of players just ripe for invasion and
It's the game with the characters who were so well designed that their souls
persisted throughout two sequels and
Their stories are the ones that inspired prepare to cry which was the series that put this channel on the map
So with that in mind, and I've been waiting a long time for the perfect moment to announce this
I'm happy to say that prepare to cry will be remastered alongside this game with better audio
Better footage and you know all the tricks that I've learned
Through the feedback that you guys have given me since those golden years when I first started. Those
stories deserve it man. They're so good. You deserve it, and this is the perfect opportunity
May 25th is gonna be one hell of a nostalgia trip with you guys and we should be able to ride that
nostalgia high ride into December, which is the absolute latest by which we've been told to wait for details regarding
Shadows Die Twice, and speaking of Shadows Die Twice which is kind of the reason I made this video
I have a few more revelations that I'd like to attach to this video that I've discovered since making
The last one on Shadows Die Twice so firstly a ton of you guys
Responded rightly to that video with the question. How come nobody has translated the Japanese script in the trailer background and
translating that was one of the first things myself and many others tried
And we all ran into the same roadblock which was that these are not modern Japanese characters in fact
They're so ancient that they're barely discernible from Chinese, and they're written in such a cursive
you know calligraphy heavy style that it makes a series of sequential
Characters really hard to read and identify my partner was able to identify the words in Chinese
for fish
tiger, shape, and maybe even blood
but at the end of the day this might just be gibberish not necessarily meant to be translated
but the most important thing you know regardless of whether we can translate one or two words is that our resident translator Loremasternojah
has said that there are Japanese specific characters here
and that they have a calligraphy style that places this era in a period before the Edo period
but after Late Antiquity
So now we have a time and place in history
to sort of work with here. The best very appropriate reference that we have is Neo
which actually takes place right before the Edo period
Japan as well
and it sets up this world where the clans of Japan were at war with another and
clashing for control of Japan and once you insert a supernatural force into the mix like in Neo and
Maybe in Blood-Borne if this is a blood-borne game
you have a hell of a story here in a setting that from software hasn't visited in a really long time and
Speaking of Blood-Borne there have been a few other links to blood-borne discovered in the trailer by user
Kordofan on Twitter who points out the striking resemblance between this chisel and the
Chisels in Garmin's workshop, which is a discovery that goes hand in hand with the next little tidbit
Which is that some of the runes on Garmin's scythe actually look a lot like Japanese?
There's a ton of good speculation. I'm gonna put in the description down below
I have a feeling all of this speculation might come to naught because we do this every year when they announced a new game
But they're teasing us for a reason, they want us to
speculate and it's fun to speculate and when it's not blood-borne and all of this gets proven wrong we still had some fun times
guessing because what else are we gonna do until Dark Souls comes out and
We can get our souls fix, but thank you all for watching
I'll see you in a couple of days because I'm about to dive into the cut content of blood-borne and
I'll see you then
Oh and before I go
It wouldn't be a VaatiVidya without diving into the deep deep lore
Behind this one-minute trailer now if you zoom into the bonfire here
Yeah, that's it and then enhance the image